minecraft memes you love them i love
them
let's watch them yeah watch till the end
of the video for a surprise
now that i'm a minecraft channel i can
finally understand
minecraft memes so i asked you guys on
twitter
send me your best minecraft memes let's
see if we can make a scrapta today
welcome to
minecraft edition
okay he's found diamonds what is the
twist a creeper
don't dig down
hey look nothing what
stop stop
[Music]
he's gonna jump in isn't he oh okay
that was a roller coaster they had us in
the first half not gonna lie i think
they had me in every half
i never felt so epically trolled smash
like if you got epically trolled
what the [ __ ] is that what the frick
this is my video
[Laughter]
it really wasn't that funny but at the
same time it was the first time we saw
creeper i mean a zombie in a minecart it
was funny
damn minecraft looked different back
then the cobblestone is everyone isn't
there
get the fraps this has to be documented
no one's ever done this yo he also
yeah he's gonna die at it
these are always so good this is my
video again minecraft veteran
you know that you can jump off a high
point and place water
right before you only pros can do it
won't take any fall damage
as such
[Music]
and that's how it's done well i can do
the life of an idiot i can laugh at my
own jokes because i don't remember them
the mental lag is brutal
that's the sad thing i was actually
trying can't wait for minecraft in 4k
damn not come on let's make it happen
since i play minecraft now i get this
joke because it's not actually minecraft
it's spyro
i'm glad i got me some donuts another
minecraft death
bring it to me
he had no loot are you kidding me i
don't believe that
see i understand this joke now it's the
eye of ender i
get it i get it i'm part of you guys i
understand the joke
it's not that funny but i get it see now
i can truly appreciate this cursed image
now that i play minecraft please kill it
why do you think i don't like watersheet
let's get real here
please stop it i don't want to see your
cursed imagery
stop it no don't do that to pee pee poo
poo
creeper
oh man how did that even happen damn
creepers
obnox feels damn proud of himself for
making
tons of gamers suffer sm edge
[Music]
i appreciate the minecraft airpods as
well i think this is more of a meme that
i'm
i can truly appreciate it it's like wine
i don't go
wow this white tastes good it's more
like that's good
i like that i like there's me another
one baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
since pewdiepie has now become a
minecraft youtuber i felt it was finally
time to become a minecraft editor
this is now a minecraft page from now on
smash like on that one thank you very
cool
[Music]
just don't mind straight down no
oh my god i got trolled epically oh
okay that was good fine that was good
rubble locks just great dude
got my freshly enchanted diamond tools
and that
um why is there going block on the
surface hey three times
only true gamers can understand this
moment only true gamers
can understand i understand like now
that i play minecraft
i understand the pain that this man is
about to get inflicted upon himself
okay what is this thing no spence
smackdown
that's a like i like that one that was
good what can i say sometimes you guys
have good memes
all right next one seven thousand seven
hundred and seventy seven
sucker seven thousand
seven got him
oh sucker good like half of the
minecraft memes is just falling or
creepers
only true minecraft gamers can
understand me
hits pigmen by accident all pigmented
nether
buenos diaz this is like the only thing
i haven't messed up yet in minecraft i'm
pretty sure i just jinxed myself yeah i
i jinxed myself
it's like it's gonna happen normally i'm
like oh pigment i should attack them
minecraft big brain
i i'm not gonna hurt i'm not having that
cool felix good do you want to tell us
any more
pointless information next hey
oh god not sven memes i can't handle it
that's awful bad guy i got
this is sad i don't like i feel you
laugh you're sad
hey dolan got one stolen you just have
to take a risk
[Music]
what just happened
it's a good mate i have seen it already
i'm sorry dolan gomez
son but like before i got it but now i
truly understand
like i bet she thought she jumped into
lava or something like crazy
watershed wait
the quality is so bad i can't see what
is that
she closes the door in her very nice
house
watershed i knew it he's invading other
people's world
in dark souls
oh that's funny oh i've seen the
original
skills around the corner
how do people do this it don't it don't
go down
it goes down it don't go don't
that's amazing 10 out of 10. smash like
and subscribe
i know what i like it's clearly people
reposting other people's content
whatever it's never stopped me before
the wi-fi password is on the back of the
router the back of the router
yeah why do they always make it so
freaking encryptic so that's the
language of the enchantments
okay see i get it now this is a
minecraft meme i get it
i don't buy you guys but i get it smash
like if you and subscribe
and buy the merch if you get it i am
wearing the merch it's just a little
chilly today okay just
just to make sure just to make sure
k-pop fans be like oh my god which one's
cute
why does villagers exist and why do they
give me nightmares i developed an ar
app from your minecraft house and put it
on the brighton beach
what the actual freakery oh my god it's
the
pier i was literally there yesterday
i didn't see it what
oh my god they're entering
what can you guys imagine why is the
swedish flag not working
that is weird what the sheep
gets revenge on pewdiepie
damn that's creepy no not the melons
i'll get you
i can't believe everyone has my freaking
world no
my diamonds what song is that
oh my god was this literally
foreshadowing for after jack black
does this mean jack black is water sheep
no stop it sven do
something worst guard dog oh
rest in peace here we go
[Music]
stop don't don't you dare touch ikea
tower
no delete this right now grande
[Music]
what is this what flag is that
no too far
too far water sheep
is norwegian it all makes sense now
no don't touch then
no no bruh
bruh
[Applause]
i'm shaking
ah not yet again he's already stopped
building up
it even has my freaking contraption dude
how
not cool man not cool guys
i fixed australia dinner bone i get it
now
[Music]
thanks guys i finally understand the
meme thank you very much thank you so
much
it took a while but i finally got there
only gamers
know the real struggle and sacrifice
when you're suffering from success
that's a decent meme i i gave a chuckle
i'm still
uh i still got my health bar though are
we still doing that no it's minecraft
okay
how do i how do i tame a parrot hey look
it's me again
i love you oh my god
oh my god
that is 10 out of 10 editing what's your
name
marty mcfly all right it's beautiful
[Music]
marty mcfly williams f's in the chat for
marty mcfly williams boys
good night girl i see you tomorrow
oh no good night girl i'll see you
tomorrow
i get it because you're not supposed to
just go in the underwater i get it
90 bug free 10 of bugs good meme i get
it if i didn't play minecraft probably
would not understand
hey yo the pizza here oh
oh my god again
i have a pizza here oh
why is this a thing i'm very confused
but it also made me laugh
and i don't know why hey look it's me
and martial
asian maybe edition question mark in the
future of course
grande this video is not for the
faint-hearted well the last one was
painful enough okay
let's watch it stop
stop oh god
hey at least you got oh come on
okay sure
what else could he possibly do to annoy
me
is that obscenity yeah okay great
i feel like the keemstar screaming meme
stop it please
now i truly know what keemstar was
screaming about while playing minecraft
oh my gosh you can't melt obsidian
[Music]
cringe
[Music]
no get biscuit nugget in a biscuit
[Music]
hey look what i didn't know that worked
stop stop
what can you possibly do with redstone
[Music]
of course
[Music]
how what how is that even possible that
makes no
sense guys see i played minecraft and i
can
i can honestly tell you guys this makes
no sense you can't just summon the
wither
he's from call of duty black ops
everyone knows that stop using my world
how did this happen
get out
oh gosh damn it don't touch sven
don't don't you dare okay good good
[Music]
[Laughter]
god damn it my mom my dad see there it
is there's a screaming keemstar
he lives in all of us
see everyone loves minecraft it brings
people together
it makes you have a good time and not
worry about all that pbs
look at that if they can get along with
warcraft
minecraft then we all care thank you so
much for watching this episode
smash like subscribe buy the merch which
i am wearing
and i see you guys next time bye
what you never play tuper simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price